donc vous propose un bilan de campagne
ce soir avec notre panel des ex jean
pierre blackburn qui est au sec n'est
yvon godin keita batos pierre paquette
qui est à montréal et en remplacement de
madame cox c'est madame céline hervieux
payette qui est avec nous à montréal je
vous dit bonsoir à vous tous
bonsoir d'entrée de jeu on va regarder
ceux ci on va le mettre en plein écran
pour que vous puissiez le voir et que
nos téléspectateurs puissent le voir
alors ce petit exercice le qui résume
les grands enjeux qui ont marqué vous
les grands moments qui ont marqué la
campagne électorale qui a commencé je
vous le rappelle le 2 ou alors vous
voyez là dessus monsieur d'ofi vous
voyez tout ce qui touche l'économie
déficit vous voyez un petit bateau qui
représente la crise des migrants le
niqab
j'ai pas besoin de vous l'expliquer ce
que vous voyez le bovin c'est l'accord
trans pacifique qui est arrivé lui aussi
et finalement ça c'est vraiment le
dernier en lice alors d'en gagner un qui
vient d'affecter la campagne libérale
alors je vais vous poser la question à
chacun parmi tout ce que je vous ai
montré là justement sur ce tableau quel
est pour vous votre événement marquant
de la campagne on va commencer avec
monsieur blackburn alors bonsoir à vous
tous pour moi l'élément marquant sa
demeure la question du niqab puisque le
prix mini à points a été le seul disons
à aller ou à reconnaître les valeurs
canadiennes en disant dès le départ il
faut que lorsque vous prêter serment que
vous devenez canadiens que vous en soyez
fiers et que ça se fasse à visage
découvert puis moi en même temps s'était
appuyé par monsieur gilles duceppe qui
pensent la même chose aux éléments
marquants d'autant plus que monsieur mal
caire c'est comme ils ont été pas
d'accord avec ça il était content pour
lui c'est correct les gens portent ni
cannes alors ça rejoint cola valeurs les
valeurs des canadiens
et là il s'est un peu empêtré dans toute
cette histoire là et ça lui a fait un
tort considérable
c'est à partir de ce moment là que les
sondages ont commencé à baisser pour lui
en pour moi la question du niqab c'est
vraiment un élément
clé de cette campagne on va aller voir
justement ce que monsieur gaudin en
pense qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce
que ça a été pour vous effectivement le
moment tournant où on a vu une sorte de
coloration collision corrélation entre
les sondages qui était plutôt favorable
à monsieur van de keere mais qui
soudainement sont mis à baisser
tranquillement mais les renie de tu sors
que ça commençait à baisser c'est que
justin trudeau lui était pur à 100%
alors c'est ça qui est très difficile à
calculer
parce que les conservateurs qui on a
voulu utiliser sort aussi bien que le
bloc québécois des gens qui étaient
contre le niqab que je pense avec
mauvaise explication parce ça seuil est
à l'essai à savoir des gens qui vont
vous le dire il faut le qualifier cet
après-midi franc contré de madame ma
carrière comme parlera encore du niqab
mais quand j ai dit que la personne
s'identifier avant m'a dit c'est quoi le
problème demain en france il ya beaucoup
de gens qui est pas informée il ya
encore beaucoup de gens qui parce que la
personne n'est pas identifiée à vendre
puis ça ça les affecte beaucoup parce
que monsieur harper l'a dit après
qu'elle a fait ça dans son mental ciel à
peut vivre au canada avec son voisin
qu'un boudreau ça dérange plus la saveur
avec toute sa méchanceté que jeudi avec
son monsieur un avis de la personne qui
la lui donne ses conseils qui vient on
s'ancre essayé qui viennent de
l'australie il dit mais j'arrive à
ottawa je vois pas ces nouveaux quais de
la fonction publique peuvent pas
travailler avec lenny calquant que sega
personnes qui travaillent dans la
fonction publique fédérale avec le niqab
alors il ya m'embrouiller les cas pour
arrêter de parler de dauphy arrêter de
parler de leurs scandales
le scandale c'est notre toutes ces
choses là et cette difficile que les
transformateurs en fait et la tristesse
du saumon je vois que monsieur 17 cents
en ligne avec monsieur harper tout le
monde s'est indigné quand monsieur
monsieur mulcair que ça soit les
conservateurs libéraux aussi bien que
que le bloc québécois et monsieur mon
père lui a tenu debout à s'attaquer
quand le premier ministre est digne que
le premier changement faut se battre
quand deux premiers ministres que tous
les gens veulent
on va continuer la tournée justement
avec votre élément selon vous le quai
marqué la campagne je reviens encore à
mon petit tableau messieurs paquet
j'aimerais ça vous entendre mais écoutez
je serai plus d'accord avec yvon sur le
fait que le niqab a sûrement joué un
rôle dans la baisse d' appui au npd
mais si c'était un élément si
déterminant que ça les libéraux au
québec en aurait subit aussi les
conséquences parce que monsieur trudeau
a été beaucoup plus clair encore que
monsieur mulcair et puis on comprend
très bien la charte des droits et
libertés c'est le legs de son père lors
qu'on soit d'accord ou pas et donc qui
s'apprend un autre élément moi je pense
que l'élément qui a été le tournant
c'est quand monsieur mulcair s'est
prononcé en faveur du déficit zéro de l'
équilibre des finances publiques à tout
prix et donc c'est un élément économique
à mon sens ce qui qui a joué et qu'il
ait repris le même discours finalement
que les conservateurs et ici au québec
de monsieur couillard et on sait qui a
voté aussi pour monsieur couillard lors
des dernières élections
et ça je pense que dans plusieurs
progressistes dans la tête de plusieurs
progrès six québécois et canadiens ça
sonner des cloches et ç'a commencé à
semer le doute et c'est rajouter à cela
un certain nombre d'autres éléments où
les positions monsieur mulcair est pas
très claire entre autres sur nrj s et ça
explique pour moi la descente actuelle
du npd alors y'a pas que le niqab
il ya toute une série d'éléments qui ont
fait qu'en voulant peut-être trop
récente et le npd il s'est fait déborder
sur sa gauche par le parti libéral et
beaucoup de monde se sont questionnés
sur leurs appuis vent selon npd et le
bloc comme les libéraux et les
conservateurs au québec peuvent
recueillir ses appuis l'eau maintenant
et c'est vrai jusqu'à 90 on peut les
voir maintenant ce qu'en pense madame
hervieux-payette alors quand vous
regardez vous ce thème rouleur qu'est ce
qui vous inspire le moment marquant je
pense que c'est la position unique de
monsieur être doux sur la question
toutes les questions économiques à
savoir ils vont investir au des nouveaux
emplois ils vont investir dans les
infrastructures en fait le gouvernement
fédéral a tellement coupé dans les
dépenses qui a provoqué lui-même cette
récession alors que effectivement je
pense qu'on avait laissé un héritage
formidable au parti conservateur lors ce
qu'ils ont mais le pouvoir il avait
effectivement
budget qui était en soi plus alors tout
ça pour vous dire qu'il ya une légère
parce que ça aussi ça aussi c'est un
tournant pour monsieur trudeau de
vraiment se distend cible d'écoutés mois
les emplois c'est important et les
questions et les programmes je vous
propose son essentiel que ce soit le
programme de garderies que ce soit les
programmes qui en soi ont été coupées
qui même à 10 au canada parce que je
pense que ça aussi c'est un enjeu qui
fournit en tout cas comme politicien on
tient à ce que notre institution
nationale demeure présente est sûre si
bien financé oui aujourd'hui ces
questions mais ça aurait un sens par
exemple parce que c'est que les libéraux
a coupé radio-canada 358 millions en
si les libéraux qui a coupé dans la
santé en 1994 c'est les libéraux qui a
coupé aussi dans les assurances chômage
57 millions qu'on veut bien le monsieur
chrétien
le champion des commandites qui se
promènent pour faire la promotion des
libéraux il ya encore jusqu'au 19
janvier
moi aussi je connais l'histoire je
connais au moins une histoire à savoir
que lorsqu'on a plus de pouvoir après le
gouvernement maroni on était dans une
situation financière dans le regret la
relance mondiale étaient prêts à nous
mettre sous surveillance
et encore on a dû payer pour des
dépenses en turquie ont été faits par le
gouvernement précédent et on les ter sur
la ligne de mire de tous les financiers
du monde alors je pense que on a réussi
à remettre sur l'économie en
internationale
non non vous avez vous avez pas
l'exclusivité d'apparat là dessus c'est
vous qui rapporte que cette question là
et je pense qu'un gouvernement
sage est un gouvernement qui aussi va
servir les intérêts des gens et faire
fonctionner l'économie est à l'heure
actuelle économique est un
ralentissement qui est absolument
inacceptable
voyez vous ramenez excusez moi monsieur
gaudin on va poursuivre ici vous ramener
le débat sur l'économie justement alors
qu'ils étaient effectivement dans les
événements et dans les grands thèmes qui
ont marqué cette campagne mais on n'a
pas parlé des débats on en a eu quand
même 5
est ce que les débats ont fait une
différence écoutez ce qu'on entend
souvent de la part des observateurs
c'est que la surprise lors du premier
débat qui était très tôt à écouter ça en
début de campagne on est
encore au mois d'août ce moment là c'est
monsieur trudeau qui avait causé la
surprise
peut-être parce qu'il y avait des
attentes qui étaient plutôt base
peut-être parce que ses attentes
barcelone de terrain avait été préparé
un petit peu par monsieur rappeur face à
monsieur trudeau qu'on présentait comme
quelqu'un qui n'était pas prêt mais
finalement on a eu une autre image de
monsieur trudeau monsieur paquet ça
faisait pas entendu mais c'est pas mon
sujet préféré parler nationale
toujours est il que dans le cadre de la
campagne électorale j'avais souligné
d'ailleurs après le premier débat que
monsieur trudeau avait surpris un peu
les gens par son attitude moi j'avais
trouvé que madame main et est meilleur
encore que monsieur trudeau mais
toujours est il que i les attentes
étaient effectivement très basse
rappelez vous il y avait un super
conservateur qui disait que s'il se
présentait avec ses pantalons aux débats
ça serait déjà une victoire
alors il ya fait plus que ça et après je
pense que maintenu quand même une bonne
une bonne prestance dans l'ensemble des
débats en particulier celui sur les
affaires étrangères - évidemment ce que
je reproche à ces débats là c'est que
monsieur duceppe a été invitée
strictement aux deux débats en français
et pas aux autres débats alors que le
bloc québécois une expertise dans
l'ensemble des domaines qui touchent le
domaine fédérale alors je pense
qu'effectivement ça a beaucoup aidés
dans le cadre des campagnes monsieur
trudeau et de vue en fin de campagne
l'adversaire à abattre parce qu'on va
très bien maintenant que toutes les
attaques elles sont concentrées sur lui
car jouer au risque où je suis pas
diplomatie c'est toujours comme ça
d'ekin un qui sort un peu du lot dont
l'ensemble des des autres partis
s'attaque c'est normal et je pense que
malheureusement la gaffe qui s'est
produit cette semaine je parle
malheureusement pour les libéraux là
encore une fois qui s'est produit avec
monsieur gagne il quand même un manque
de jugement total remet en cause je
dirais la crédibilité de monsieur
trudeau concernant sa volonté vraiment
changer la culture politique et le parti
libéral et la culture politique à ottawa
particulièrement lorsqu'il parle de
transparence encore une fois si monsieur
garnier s'est senti à l'aise d'envoyer
ce courriel le haut dirigeant de
transcanada c'est qu'il avait vraiment
l'impression que ça ne s'était pas en
dehors
j'irai des paramètres de monsieur
trudeau et de l'ensemble de l'équipe
alors ça c'est inquiétant un peu
monsieur trudeau à une réaction correct
mais ça c'est pas suffisant pour
dissiper les inquiétudes qu'on peut
avoir sur l'avenir
ouais alors peut-être un dernier thème
maintenant avec vous monsieur blackburn
et qu'est ce que ça marche cette
histoire de caisses enregistreuses on va
voir un petit exemple ici de ce qu'on a
entendu toute la semaine avec monsieur
rap
il s'est promené avec la même stratégie
de communication on prend une personne
dans la salle qui représentent la
population aux terres où une mère de
famille on parle du coup finalement
qu'auront les libéraux si jamais des été
porté au pouvoir avec ce bruit de
caisses enregistreuses vous l'avais
répété toute la semaine du côté des
conservateurs pourquoi alors pour moi
c'est parce que ça symbolise la
différence entre les différents
programmes de chacune des formations
politiques ont su monsieur harper ses
budgets équilibrés
pas de hausse de taxes pas de hausse
d'impôt
monsieur mulcair du npd lui ces budgets
équilibrés même chose les taxes chose
les impôts parce que j'ai promis
beaucoup et monsieur trudeau déficit de
30 milliards alors difficile de 30
milliards et dit oui à tout il ne manque
que chausson aux pommes qui n'est pas
encore offert aux canadiens
mais faut être conscient falloir payer
la facture et cette façon là de montrer
ce que les hausses d'impôts vont faire
au canadien ça veut dire à chaque fois
que j'entendais la caisse sonné c'est de
l'argent que vous enlevez de vos proches
pour leur donner à l'époque parce que
certains politiciens comme monsieur
marqueur monsieur trudeau veulent aussi
les taxes les impôts mais quand martel
est révélée prévenir une image comme
celle là avec ce bruit l'ajustement
grosse quand même est-ce que ce n'est
pas justement parce que on sent que le
désir de changement est très très
présents dans là dedans la population et
puis il ya un petit peu d'énergie du
désespoir là dedans je me permets de
dire vous savez monsieur à peu on se
prend toute une force de caractère pour
passer à travers cette campagne vous
avez de multiples groupes de pression de
syndicats qui bien sûr critique
constamment le gouvernement pour lui
malgré ça il réussit à garder le cap ne
se charge pas été présent de quoi qui
est intéressant pour les canadiens qui
est stable avec un budget équilibré
alors pour moi c'est quand on compare
les trois et il faut revenir quand vous
venez revenir parce que c'est vraiment
tout le temps qui nous étaient dévolues
je vous avez quand même laisser le mot
de la fait écouter la seule chose qu'on
peut dire maintenant c'est d'encourager
les gens qui nous écoutent à aller voter
en large et c'est le jeudi
merci à toute seule j'ai un coup de
coeur dans ce cas par des paroles voir
car on va laisser aux électeurs le 10
juin